we're joined now by the republican
governor of maryland larry hogan
governor good morning
good morning governor thanks so much for
joining us as we just heard in paula
reed's piece only a fraction of those 20
million vaccinations at operation warp
speed projected for the end of the year
have actually been administered
president trump says the federal
government did its part in getting those
vaccinations to states
now as a leader of your state where is
the backup exactly and do you have
enough federal support
well look i think in the middle of this
is the most important battle of this
entire war against the virus and it's
it's a bad time to be pointing fingers
when we really just have to bring
everybody at the federal state and local
and the private sector together to get
this done but you know the good
news is that they actually are years
ahead of schedule with operation warp
speed and getting these
vaccines approved and we have gotten our
first
our first batches out from the federal
government a little less than we
anticipated but we've now in our state
gotten them to every single hospital
every single nursing home and every
single local health department who now
has to actually get the people organized
and
get the vaccinations into people's arms
but there's no question that we all
need to be ramping up if we're going to
get this enormous
job done at the across the country it's
absolutely all hands on deck but where
exactly are you seeing the slowdown what
parts of the supply chain
are not working or where is it that the
vaccine is is
not getting to people's arms
i think it's a little bit about all
across the board so
the federal government did not deliver
the number that they were originally
uh you know telling the states that they
would get the uh
private sector companies the two the two
currently two companies but several more
are getting close but the two companies
in production i think their production
has not been as fast as uh
as they had hoped or their what their
projections were
and then there really wasn't a lot of
support uh no financial support and no
real plan the states came up with their
own plans and it included
sending these from the federal
government directly to the hospitals and
the nursing homes and
they're having a little bit of time
getting ramped up as well because it's a
it's a massive undertaking and they've
got to organize it
in such a way that they can make sure to
get the second dose
uh within the couple week period that
are required so it's not just sticking
needles in arms
there's a lot of moving parts and i
think
nobody is quite performing at the
top capacity and we've all got to work
together to ramp it up
governor moving on to this new strain
that's discovered here in the u.s the
one that has spread through the uk
how concerned are you that that's
already in maryland and what do states
need to do to protect people
well we're very concerned about the new
strain i guess the good news is that it
doesn't appear to be more deadly
and that it appears as if the vaccines
will be effective against the new strain
but the bad news is that it's
it's so much more contagious and really
ramps up
the transmission rate the positivity
rates in a
in a in a rapid way so
we're worried about it we haven't seen
any signs of it yet in our state we know
we
saw the first case in colorado we
haven't had direct flights from
from britain uh british airways was
flying into
baltimore washington international
airport but that's been that was
suspended back in march
we've got some pretty serious travel
restrictions but there's
no way to stop the virus from sneaking
across
you know we we expect that all of our
entire team has been focused on what to
do when we do
have to face that governor hogan thank
you
thank you